est ce qu'il vous reste une petite place
on appelle ce type le bourg
quand il ya mort ou vif écrit sur la
fiche nous autres on tire dans le dos du
haut de note vers soirée en rapporte au
cac d'afficher sur la selle mais site
est arrêté par john roos le bourreau tu
te balance au bout d'une corde attraper
elle s'était dit domergue elle est
recherchée morte ou vive pour meurtre
quand le soleil aura décidé de feu levée
j'emmène cette femme se faire pendre il
y aurait t'il quelqu'un ici qui se
serait juré de m'empêcher de faire ça
parfois on dirait que la mercerie de
mini va être fort conviviale ces
prochains jours
c'est ce que je me dis aussi
yann c bonne offre
ce n'est pas lui qui prétend être
au moindre geste pelous vous prenez une
panne sans préavis
les questions une bâche
mieux ça
où